The greatest public speakers became great
because they eventually found their voice.
Not somebody else's voice, but their voice.
Let me explain to you what I mean by that.
Have you ever sat in a room where somebody
is speaking and it's so awkward or uncomfortable
that you truly cannot wait to leave the room.
Like you are going lower in your chair and
you're trying to hide and maybe putting the
hat down.
You just don't want to be seen, and you're
feeling sorry for the speaker.
Why is that?
Here's why.
It's because the person is trying to speak
like somebody else, and they're not that person,
they're not like the other person.
The best way to give an analogy that will
make sense to you is this.
Think about music.
How many different music genres are there?
Think about all the different music genres
that we have.
Now I want you to visualize this.
Take Tupac.
Imagine Tupac singing country music.
Can you see it?
I can't see it.
Like imagine he's [singing country style].
I can't even do it right now.
[Singing].
It's his song.
Now take Blake Shelton.
Now imagine Blake Shelton, we ask him to sing
hip hop.
Can you see it?
Can you truly see it?
Can you see Blake Shelton singing hip hop?
I can't see it.
Because that's not his voice.
And that's not Tupac's voice.
And you need to find your voice.
And when people ask me this most random question,
"Pat, I want to be a better public speaker.
What can I do?"
Find your voice!
Stop trying to be somebody else's voice.
What does that even mean?
So finally, instead of answering hundreds
of emails that I get on this, I decided to
make video again.
Keep in mind, every single video I make, I
make because the question gets asked so many
times I eventually make a video about it.
So let's get right into it.
I've got some points that I'll give you about
speaking, 16 of them, but before getting into
it, I first want to tell you multiple styles
of public speakers, and you need to ask yourself
which one is you and identify with that speaker
and then go study speakers that have that
style because that's your style, if that makes
sense.
So let's get right into it.
#1: Mentor/Advisor
So who is the mentor/advisor?
This could be a Tony Robbins type of a speaker.
When he speaks, he can't help himself but
give you advice.
He can't help himself but give you direction.
He can't help himself but lead you, right?
Here's what I would do.
. . because that's their style.
The mentor/advisor, high, high energy, that's
a Tony Robbins.
#2: Charm/Humor
This could be a Ronald Reagan.
When he would speak, I can't think of a time
when he spoke where he didn't have a joke
to say.
It was always humor, charm, smile.
His pacing was slow.
He wasn't the fast talking guy.
Tony Robbins can run laps around Ronald Reagan
when it comes to speaking, because Tony can
say a thousand words in 30 seconds and Reagan
is just on number 68, for instance.
I'm giving you an example here.
So charm/humor may be a Ronald Reagan, with
a sense of humor.
You may say, "I have a great sense of humor."
Use it.
"People have told me I'm charming."
Go study Ronald Reagan.
#3:Bold, Yet Credible
Somebody may say, "Well, I'm more like bold,
you know, I just kind of want to tell people
off, but I know what I'm talking about."
Well then that's Gary Vaynerchuk.
He's extremely bold.
He'll get up and curse the entire audience
out, but he knows what he's talking about.
So bold, yet credible.
Some people say, "I don't like Gary's style."
He's not talking to you!
He's got his own style.
But he's bold, yet credible.
Some people don't like Reagan.
I know people that say, "I can't even listen
to Tony Robbins' voice.
I can't listen to Tony Robbins."
He's not speaking to you.
You're not the audience.
#4: Locker Room Talk
You may say, "You know what?
I'm more like the locker room type of guy.
I like to sit down and tell people what they
need to be doing."
Great.
You may study Mike Ditka.
Mike Ditka was a locker room talk type of
a guy.
He sat there and told people, "Here's what
you need to do."
And he was locker room, fired everybody up,
ticked them off and boom!
They're ready to go to war.
That's Mike Ditka.
Go study Mike Ditka, the coach of the Chicago
Bears.
A lot of people don't like him, but he did
very well as a player and as a football coach.
#4:
Another one may be commanding, firm, generalesque,
like Netanyahu.
Prime Minister Netanyahu from Israel just
recently gave a talk to the United Nations,
I believe.
He gave a talk that I recommend you listen
to because he was firm, slow, bold, he respected
everybody, opened it up with respect to everybody,
but he made his point.
Commanding, firm, generalesque.
That may be you.
Many people don't like his style, but you
may speak like that.
You need to be true to your voice.
#6: Crusade
The next one is crusade.
You may be a crusader, and nobody really understands.
What do you mean you're a crusader?
Why do you always talk about correcting an
injustice?
Maybe you need to study MLK, Billy Graham,
Malcolm X.
By the way, conflicting beliefs.
Malcolm X and MLK and Billy Graham, they're
not the same beliefs, but they had a crusade.
It was a cause, right?
So that's the category I would be studying
if that's your style of speaking.
You may say, "That's not me."
Then keep continuing on the next people.
#7: Storyteller
Imagination.
Steve Jobs.
Steve Jobs does not speak like Ronald Reagan
or speak like Tony Robbins or Gary or any
of these other guys.
But when Steve Jobs spoke, people listened
because he was an incredible storyteller and
he was an unbelievable guy at making you and
I imagine things that weren't possible.
Can you imagine if you and I. . . the Walkman,
and all of a sudden he takes out the iPod.
Oh my gosh!
It's an iPod!
Can you imagine having a computer within your
hands and he takes out an iPad.
Do you remember the first time you and I found
out about iPads?
Everybody wanted one.
Remember the first time somebody had an iPod?
How did you and I react?
How many songs?
5,000 songs!
That's like me having 5,000 CDs.
Imagination.
Can you imagine if you have an iPod, iPod
Touch, iPad all together, called the iPhone!
I mean, it's imagination.
So maybe your gift is imagination.
#9: Presence
What's presence?
Oprah Winfrey.
When she enters a room, presence entered.
There's presence.
So her speaking style may be presence.
It may be curiosity.
It may be questions that she does.
But that's her style.
#10: Arrogant
You know what arrogant is?
This is not who you want to be.
This is somebody that acts like they know
what they're talking about, yet everybody's
thinking they're full of it.
Kanye West.
And there are many people like that out there.
But he has a lot of people that follow him.
That's great.
A lot of people follow many different people
for different reasons.
If that's your style, where you want to convince
people that you know what you're talking about
but you don't?
That's a style.
I just don't recommend that style.
#11:Sales
The next one is sales, somebody that's an
incredible salesman.
Incredible salesmen may be Warren Buffett.
I mean, Warren Buffett can sell you, you can
sit with Warren Buffett and he can convince
you to drink eight cans of coke for the rest
of your life and you would do it.
Starting tomorrow you would say, "Hey, can
we get a case of Coca Cola?"
Because every day Warren Buffett lives 88
years, I need to drink eight cans of Coke
a day," and you would drink it because he's
a salesman.
He can't help himself, but sell.
Everywhere he goes, he sells.
Geico Cadillac, dealerships, furniture, he
just wants to sell, and he's a great salesman.
If that's you, that's the style.
Listen to Warren Buffett talk, you'll know
exactly what I'm talking about.
#7: Seductive
The next is seductive.
Maybe you're the seductive type of speaker.
Maybe you speak and you seduce people.
Maybe you have your own charming, seductive
way.
Well maybe you need to study JFK and Bill
Clinton.
They were some of the most seductive speakers
of all time.
Bill Clinton could give you a talk, look at
you and say something and you would say, "I
have no idea if he's telling the truth, but
man, I believe him."
It's like you're being hypnotized.
You're seduced.
You're in a whole different land.
That's a seductive speaker.
#13: Technical
Then you have the technical speaker.
Very, very detailed, technical.
You know, like if you watch some of Elon Musk's
talks, it's such a technical speech when he
speaks.
It's all technical details that he gets into
and a whole different style of speaking.
#14: Inspirational
And then you have inspirational.
What's an inspirational speaker?
Inspirational speaker could be Barack Obama.
He is inspirational.
He sells you the dream.
Like, we are going somewhere.
Because he's an inspirational speaker.
And he doesn't do it a million miles a minute.
It's just music, the way he does it.
It's just flowing when he does it.
And he moves you.
#15: Philosophical
And then there's philosophical, which could
be who?
That could be Phil Jackson.
He makes you question things.
You'll talk to Phil Jackson and he'll make
you question things.
People say, "Hey Phil, why did you do.
. . " and he says, "Why do you think I did
. . . " And why do you think such and such
did this, this, this?
And you say, "But I didn't ask you that question."
"But I want it answered" and you give the
answer.
Oh!
So it's the speaker that makes you constantly
go "Oh, now it makes sense."
Philosophical speaker.
Maybe that's you.
Maybe you study Marcus Aurelius or all the
different religions.
Maybe you study every single philosophy from
stoicism to cynicism to.
. . every one of them you study so you're
philosophical.
You like to question things.
Great.
That's your style.
#16: Fear
And then there's fear type of leaders.
People that put the fear into everybody and
people perform.
What's fear?
Bobby Knight, Pat Riley.
I mean, I can give you a list of names.
Fear.
Go study Bobby Knight.
Go study Pat Riley.
But Pat Riley was like a gangster, mafia type
of a coach in the NBA, right?
That's who he was.
And people would just, they wanted to play
for this guy, because he just knew how to
get people to get aligned and then boom, we're
going to beat the other guy.
And people believed it.
And they did.
He got 5 championships as a coach, and obviously
he's got three of them as a general manager
president with Miami.
He's done a fantastic job.
Probably one of the best GMs.
If it wasn't for him LeBron James probably
wouldn't have gone to Miami.
So, that's his style.
By the way, just so you know, many of you
admire at least two or three of the people
that I just mentioned.
But I guarantee you that if I ask you right
now to comment on the bottom and post the
one you like the most out of everybody I said,
I promise you you're all going to be the same.
Some of you will say, "Who is Netanyahu?"
But some of you will say, "Netanyahu was amazing."
Steve Jobs is my favorite!
Mine is Barack Obama.
But it's going to be different.
It doesn't matter.
It's your voice.
What's your voice?
Find your voice, and don't try to be anybody
else when you're speaking.
Now, there are some areas that you can figure
out ways to become better tactically or skill
set.
I'm going to do my best to try to give you
some skills, but there's a whole technical
side to speaking.
How big is the stage?
Do you walk?
It there a podium?
Is the mic over here?
Do you hold the mic?
Is it a wireless mic?
Is is tied here?
Can you walk around?
Do you need to make sure the speakers are
on this side so you don't make that sound
[microphone squeal].
You need to know your real estate.
There are things that you need to know, but
that's technical stuff.
Forget about the technical stuff.
Technical stuff happens after you've given
thousands of talks, you'll realize about the
different AV systems, lighting, where you
need to stand to have the lighting perfect,
and your face.
That's purely technical.
I'm giving you basic how-to.
I'm not getting technical here.
I'm giving you basic how-to when it comes
down to speaking, and hopefully some of these
things can help you out.
Listen, for me, when I think about a great
public speaker, this is my #1.
Let me tell you what my #1 is.
If I can go and hear somebody speak - whoever
it is - any one of these guys.
If I can go and hear somebody speak, and the
entire time, when this person is speaking,
if I go hear somebody speak, and I feel like,
the audience could have thousands of people
in the room, but I feel like it's just me
and the person speaking?
That to me is a great speaker.
If it's just you and I. That to me is a great
speaker.
If I get lost during his speech, and I forget
everybody else is in the room, I forget I'm
watching a video.
I forget I'm watching a movie.
I'm watching, like for instance, when Gladiator,
when Russell Crowe gives that one speech,
no one exists and you're just in the movie,
you are there.
Or when Braveheart, what's his name, Mel Gibson
gets up and he gives that one speech, you
watch that.
No one exists.
Right?
Or you're Denzel Washington give a talk in
John Q, I'm not going to bury my son.
My son's going to bury who?
Me.
You're lost.
It's one person.
If a speaker knows how to do that, they all
do it in their own separate ways.
That to me is a great speaker.
So if you can captivate me to the point where
I think it's just you and I, as if you and
I are having a cup of coffee or we're having
lunch and I'm simply listening to you speak,
you've already won.
You don't even need to watch the rest of the
video.
Turn off the video and skip to another video.
You don't need to watch anything else.
If you learn how to do that, the rest is over
with.
The rest is over with.
Because all of the other stuff, you'll pick
up by doing so many times of speaking, you'll
get better at it.
Next thing.
#2 to me is somebody that is very good at
making their point by telling stories.
Sometimes when I get asked to speak for three
hours and they want to do Q&A, that's a different
talk than when it's for an hour, to just give
a presentation than it is from hey, can you
give a 10-minute talk here?
Then a 5-minute talk.
If I'm asked to talk 5 minutes on TV or on
whatever it is that I'm speaking for five
minutes, here's a point, here's a story.
Done.
Let me tell you about what's going on over
here.
Here's the conditions that we're looking at
right now.
. . . Here's what I think we need to consider
changing to.
And here's what I believe will be the solution.
Let me tell you why I believe this.
I remember when it was 1992 and boom.
Story.
So get into your story, when you wanted to
make your point, tell stories.
Somebody who is very good at making stories
and figuring out ways for me to take a metaphor
or an analogy, that makes sense, I got it.
I respond to that, and most people respond
to that as well if you're telling your story.
#3:Make Your Case
So look at speaking as these three different
points.
Write these three points down so you can kind
of understand what I'm saying with this.
First, state your facts.
For instance, "Unemployment right now in America
is 9.2%" (It's not, I'm just making it up.)
"Here's what I think we need to do.
We need to get people going back to jobs by
lowering the taxes."
Or "we need to raise the taxes and tax the
top 1% and make them pay the bottom 80%.
That's what we need to do.
And if we do this, I believe unemployment
is going to go from 9.2% to 4.3%."
Take that three format -- state the facts,
make your argument, why they should join you.
State your facts, make your argument, why
they should join you.
Just follow that format.
And by the way, practice this and with any
argument, it doesn't matter what it is, take
anything, follow those three steps, and look
at what will happen.
Then you'll get judged based on how well you
do in the middle.
Think about it.
This is when you speak like that and you're
an attorney, you're going to get judged based
on the middle.
By the way, this could happen with family
as well.
You're sitting there saying, "Listen.
Let's state the facts.
Let's say you're talking to your kid.
Here's your grades.
And let me explain to you what I think is
taking place.
I think one of the reasons is because you're
doing this, this, this, and I think if you
do this, here's what could happen.
And you always wanted to play baseball for
Pepperdine University because that's the way
you want to go into major league baseball,
this is your opportunity.
So I think if you do this, here's a fact,
we can get some scholarships, you can go play
for Pepperdine and maybe one day you'll play
major league baseball.
What do you say?
What do you think about that?
Three step process.
Those three.
State your facts, make your argument, and
why they should join you, and if they do what's
going to happen.
So you're speaking like an attorney because
you're making a case.
#4: If you are a first time speaker, or you've
only spoken a handful of times, typically
things that will make you sound like you know
what you're doing, you've done this a few
times before, let's just say you got three
points you're making.
To each point, add a quote to it.
Winston Churchill once said, history will
be kind to me for I intend to write it.
I think we need to focus on writing our own
history by writing our goals and commitments
on what we want to do.
Okay, great.
"Imagination is more important than knowledge"
was said by Einstein.
I think sometimes we spend too much time on
the facts and today we need to spend some
time on our dreams.
That's your point #2, dreams.
But point, quote, point, quote, point, quote,
especially if you're newer.
The more you speak, the more you read, the
more quotes you have in your repertoire, they're
going to come out, just purely by you having
done these talks so many times.
So add a quote, it will make it a lot easier
for you.
#5: Connect with the Audience
How do you connect with the audience?
Look at them, and make eye contact with them.
Make eye contact with them.
And choose a handful of people that are engaged
the most, and make eye contact with them.
Don't worry about the guy yawning.
Don't even look at the person that's yawning.
They're going to confuse you.
Look at the person that is fully engaged,
and make eye contact.
Keep going back, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Especially when you're newer.
Make eye contact, and by the way, one thing
you don't want to do is just stay on one person.
A lot of times amateurs stay on one person,
and that person is very uncomfortable and
everybody else is saying, hey, do you want
to talk to us as well?
So you have to make sure you're dancing [looking
side to side], dancing with everybody.
Eye contact everywhere.
#6: Next is I said it already, don't try to
sound like others.
Pick your voice, and stick to that voice and
who you are.
You can many times ask somebody on your style
of speaking and if you made a list of these,
and you put them out there, someone's going
to say, You know what, I see you more as the
this type of a speaker.
Great.
Then take that and ask yourself which one
you are, and work on that type of a speaker.
But make sure you're staying true to your
own voice.
#7: Preparation
Simple as that.
When I first started speaking initially and
I was very nervous about speaking.
The first time I spoke, I spoke at Denny's
in Compton.
Out of all the places, I spoke at a Denny's
And it was last minute, the speaker just asked
me to come up and I was not prepared to speak.
I had never spoken in my life.
I'm a military guy, but he asked me to come
up.
And I went up, and I couldn't wait to sit
down.
It was the worst talk I ever gave in my life.
I was nervous like you wouldn't believe.
And then from there I started doing more of
them and then eventually there was a system
to it.
But I realized if I'm not a pro, because I
haven't given thousands of talks in my life,
I need to make sure I over prepare.
So I focused on preparation.
The easiest way, sometimes people try to write
their entire speech, that's okay.
I don't recommend it because I don't listen
when somebody writes their entire speech.
So I'm telling you as a listener, I will not
listen to your speech if you just write the
whole script, and you're going through it.
You're going to have a hard time getting my
attention if you're just you know, people
will do one of these things they'll say, you
know, I'm so nervous I'm just going to read
my speech.
Okay so, "Hi. . .[reading in monotone]."
You lost me already.
I'm gone.
So I suggest taking a card, make five bullet
points, and under each bullet point make three
points if you need to make it and add a story
to it.
You may put something like "Volkswagen story"
and you know what the Volkswagen story is,
so get into it.
Hugo Boss story.
This is a suit one time you had and it ripped
and you went on to the appointment and they
laughed at you and you realized before they
even laughed at you that you were going to
tell them, I'm so sorry, when I was coming
in, I hit the door and I cut my pants, so
my apologies for these pants and I'll make
sure I get it fixed before the next time we
meet together.
Haha.
Let's get into the meeting.
For instance.
But that's your story, okay?
So the more prepared you are as a rookie,
the better it is.
Even as a veteran, but as a rookie, even more
important.
#8: What is your outcome?
What is truly your outcome for giving the
talk?
What is your ideal outcome of what you want
to start seeing happen with this talk?
What is the action item?
What do you want them to talk action with?
Truly.
Is it to buy?
Is it to register?
Is it to sign up?
Is it to subscribe?
Is it to move?
It is to be somewhere else?
Is it to.
. . so what is your outcome?
What is truly your outcome of this talk you're
giving?
Be very specific of your outcome and make
sure you're staying true to your outcome.
Sometimes you're giving so much, like I'm
doing such a good job!
And then you finish and you're like, I didn't
even hit my outcome!
What is your outcome?
#9: Know your audience
It's very important to know who you're speaking
to.
So, how old are they?
Income?
Where are they from?
Why are they there to hear you?
Do they care to hear you?
Do they like you?
Do they even know who you are?
Do they pay attention?
Are they younger?
If they're younger, how much of an attention
span do they have?
I've spoken in front of prisons.
I've spoken in front of people who just got
out of prison.
I've spoken in front of billionaires.
I've spoken in front of millionaires.
I've spoken in front of clergy.
I've spoken in front of atheists.
I've spoken in front of a debate politically.
So who is your audience that you're speaking
to?
Then you'll know how to make the adjustments
based on the audience you're speaking to.
#10: Action Items
Put your action items, similar to your outcome,
but action items.
My action items are first I want them to do
this, two I want them to do that, three I
would like them to do this.
So 10, give your action items.
Point #1, here's what I want you to do.
I want you to go and do . . . go to the website
and register.
#2, I need you to send me an email, right
now, take out your phone and send me an email
and tell me what is the thing that you're
going to be changing about yourself today?
Whatever it is.
And 3, the pamphlet I have underneath you,
when you're leaving, I need you to come to
my booth, when you're leaving, I need you
to go buy this book.
It doesn't matter.
Give your action items when you're leaving.
#11: typically it's good to come and meet
the audience before, shake hands, greet, talk
to people, let them get to know you, you get
to know them.
There's some kind of a relationship going
on, and when you're speaking from stage you
can typically identify one of the people you
spoke with and that helps out a lot when you're
speaking.
#12: Edify the venue and the organization
that brought you up.
For instance, if you're speaking somewhere
and they ask you to speak, don't right off
the bat go and say thank you so much for this
-- you're too black and white.
Get into it and break the ice and talk and
then five minutes into it say hey, by the
way, thank you for the invite, but make sure
you're recognizing the people that gave you
that platform because without that platform,
you wouldn't have the platform and the audience
you're speaking to.
#13: Disturb
The greatest speakers I know know how to disturb
and move people.
These guys [fear] are good at disturbing.
Great leaders are phenomenal at disturbing
and getting people to move.
You better believe crusade speakers are very
much about disturbing.
Bold yet credible are all about disturbing.
Locker room talk are about disturbing.
Commanding, they're about disturbing.
So figure out a way how to disturb and make
me move.
So think about people that spoke to you, how
did it make you move?
You be that person to your audience.
#14: Challenge them
There's got to be a challenge.
I have a challenge for you.
Here's my challenge to you.
My challenge to you is to do this, this, this.
So there's got to be a challenge given to
everybody.
The greatest talk ever you give, without a
challenge at the end, is worthless.
Just so you know.
If I don't leave after hearing you speak and
I don't take any action and don't have a challenge
I need to be doing, your talk was a waste
of time.
Within an hour I'm over it already.
No one's talking about it.
But you need to give me a challenge.
The best type of speakers are the ones that
I walk away from saying, "Man, I feel like
I'm not good enough.
I've got to improve on this.
I've got to do this."
Challenge.
I have a challenge.
What is your challenge you're going to give
to your audience?
#15: Rehearse
Practice your talk, especially if you're newer,
in front of other people.
#16: Get Your Timing Right
What is timing?
When you put your story here.
When you disturb.
When you do this.
Sports is all about timing.
This [shooting a basket] is timing.
Football is timing.
Golf is timing.
This is a game of timing.
Speaking is also timing.
And by the way, with timing, timing is probably
the last thing you're going to pick up because
it's not going to come right off the bat.
You won't get timing until you give 100, 200,
300 talks.
So just something to be thinking about and
the more you give, you'll know what I mean
by timing.
Comment on the bottom and I'll do my best
to get back to you with the comments, but
timing comes later.
That doesn't come early on.
Those are some points I have for you.
How many of them was it?
Was it 16 points I got for you on how to become
a better public speaker.
But you may want to go back and look at these
and pick and choose who it is and start studying
that person's style of speaking and mainly
focus on that person's style of speaking.
Don't try to be somebody you're not, and you'll
be amazed by the type of talks you'll eventually
start giving.
And by the way, keep this in mind.
It helps to give a lot of talks so this is
one of the benefits of being an entrepreneur
and being in sales you have many different
opportunities to give talks to your sales
organization.
Sometimes people who are involved in sales
end up becoming great speakers because they
have more opportunities to give talks than
somebody who is not.
So I highly recommend being involved in some
type of a sales organization, sales model,
where you can constantly be doing this to
see the reaction you're getting, the response
you're getting from everybody.
So now, with that being said, I do not think
we have the pillow here.
Actually, as a matter of fact, it's right
here.
Mike, if you can get this for us.
Hey, you got any questions, post them on the
bottom.
If you haven't subscribed yet, please be sure
to do so.
This subscribe pillow was at Harvard, Boston
for the last 3, 4 weeks.
Paul literally just got back today.
So make sure to subscribe.
We have a very special episode that's coming
in when we cross 100,000 fans that we're going
to need your help.
We're going to put a lot of you guys in the
video and I'll tell you how that's going to
be, so stay tuned for the email that's going
to go out and a video I'll post to tell you
exactly what we're doing once we reach 100,000.
I think right now we're at 97,000 subs or
so.
While you're watching this video we may already
cross 100,000 by the time some of you watch
it so again, subscribe and please, if you
think this is a video that's going to help
some of your teammates, some of the other
people that you may know in your business,
in your company, be sure to share this video
as well with everybody else.
Thanks for watching everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.